hello
welcome to our career webinar
challenging the status quo
expert tips on making 2021 the best year
for your career
our guest today to read to uh today this
morning
i should say is ritu aparna chopper
barty uh the
co-founder and evp of teamless team
leads
services limited and our
webinar today is also sponsored by one
of their companies freshers world
my name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at
simply learn before we get started i'd
like to
remind everybody of how the webex
controls work
for questions that you will get answered
by youtube at the end of the
presentation put them in the q a box
please
um and that way we can cue them up for
her
um if you do put information in the chat
please address it to
all panelists uh so that
both i and she can see that
and the first thing we're going to do
is a poll i will be doing a few of these
during the presentation
sorry and
give me a moment to get it started
this poll has two questions
and if you're watching on youtube or
linkedin live
go ahead and put your answers in the
comments
for the rest of you you should see the
webex polling widget
and the first question is what's your
level of experience
and the second question is one that
we've been asking since the start of the
pandemic
about how you're doing personally at
this time
know that things are not going well
in general in india right now but we
hope that you personally are doing
all right staying safe and well
and we have about 10 seconds left on
this pole
and we'll close it five
four three two
one and
let me share the results
and we have a pretty experienced
audience it's a bimodal distribution but
about half of people have five or more
years experience
and then there's about a third who are
still at college or university and i'm
glad to see that
most everybody is doing at least okay
and or better than that and for the
people who are not
we hope that the information in the
webinar will
help lighten your mood a little bit so
let me
close this poll and introduce our guest
of honor
uh ritu chakravarti is the co-founder
and evp
of teamly services she has 21
and more years of experience in the
industry
and she has been instrumental in making
team lease
india's largest people supply chain
company
she has a number of honors including
winning the telstra business woman in
asia award
and she has her economics undergraduate
degree from benares
hindu university and her mba from go
institute of management
so welcome and uh thank you for joining
us today rita
thank you and i'm going to um
stop sharing these slides so that we can
have a conversation
there we go
so um if i could start with a question
you know what is different about
the world of work today
um than it was before the pandemic hit
first and foremost uh thank you so much
for having me
in this uh in this
interesting event that you've lined up i
hope everybody's
staying safe and doing well okay so i
think um
covet i believe has not created so many
new trends as it has
amplified existing ones uh and i think
few uh aspects of
it which has pro which has probably
become very apparent and visible
across the world is that uh two things i
mean very simply put is one is the
impact of
digital tools technologies uh
in at workplaces and in our daily lives
as well as the way we are
as as well as the way we learn i think
these are the two things
where i personally have seen that the
maximum
amplification or that
has happened and i think if uh it's
important for us
honestly to jump into
uh these two aspects as early as we can
otherwise we will definitely get left
out in terms of the direction
that workplaces organizations
enterprise structures job roles um
are about to take or probably has
already transformed into
so i think uh from my perspective of
course there is
i mean a question as open-ended as this
can have extremely um
broad response like starting from how
education has changed how health care
systems are changing
um how um individual consumption
patterns are changing
how how uh traditional
consumption models are probably going to
be changed forever
how real estate is changing but i'm not
delving into all of those aspects but
given the context of today's discussions
i think the two things which
have got amplified thanks to the
pandemic are
digital technologies and its impact on
our lives and learning
just to answer as briefly as i can on
that point
yeah as an um
early in the pandemic i was watching a
a webinar from a company actually a
investment firm that was talking about
different companies that they had in
their portfolio and
they one of the executives said you know
if
someone had come to us and said
we need to shift all of our workers to
work from home
we would have said to management that's
going to take six months and it will
cost
10 million dollars and then
we got the word we all have to work from
home tomorrow
and within three days and in no budget
everybody was working from home so yeah
your point about amplifying trends and
the idea that
digital transformation was a popular
topic
in 2019 but it became
vitally essential in 2020
is a very germane one um
how do you see change in
in both the digital nature
of our lives and our work as well as um
as learning as a priority and as a
as a methodology in 2021 how do you see
that
being different going into the future
let me walk into responding to that
question after i probably share a few
comments on
uh why i particularly stayed away from
making
any comment around the work from home
thing which has been much talked about
right stewart i think it's very
important that why did i
uh specifically stayed away why because
i think in india i think these are
context of course that i can share from
uh from india that we have
seen a roller coaster ride when it comes
to
this whole work from home concept and
let me explain why
i think it's very important to
understand this before i respond to
the question that you asked right now uh
we went from as you rightly pointed out
and i think i did some research around
the same time last year and i found out
that
even if i consider the most advanced
technology companies globally
uh before walking into the pandemic not
more than 20 percent of the workforce
global workforce was working from home
and um and this is this is specifically
to the technology
companies that we're talking about i'm
not considering any other industries in
this statistic
so if even the most advanced technology
companies were
actually with all the tools available at
their hand was working at 20
um and how do you then manage the shift
of course we saw
world reacting to the pandemic and a lot
of organizations were able to make
a switch like we did like ours is a
services company and
it was absolutely an unthinkable concept
i mean how do you manage your employees
how do you get them to become productive
if they're gonna not be in front of you
i think these were obvious questions
every uh leader probably we're
struggling
with but we managed to do it right as in
reaction and i think successfully so
and i think there were some extremely um
extremely bold statements made by many
industry leaders
and tech giants saying that uh
75 80 90 of our workforce will be
working home for the next three years
and stuff like that
and maybe we will never go back to home
however we have seen the same
organizations come back and say
the leader is saying this is not working
out we want to come back to workforce
because you know finally we cannot
undermine the importance of social
capital
i think we utilize the social capital
that we had created before the pandemic
to see through the first six months of
the pandemic when we were doing
video meetings and collaborations online
channels because you
already could bank on that social
capital however
you know there are many employees who
have joined during the pandemic
with this kind of a setup they are
struggling to build that social capital
with their peers
and i think we have to realize that we
are social animals
you know yes there that flexibility
should be available for us to work from
home and we should be equipped
but i don't think it will be a complete
phenomenon where we will all shift
to work from home you will see people
and i i know in uk in u.s many people
want to come back to workplaces for the
same reason
so i guess that's it but i think digital
technology actually has empowered us
to have the flexibility of choosing when
we want to work from home and when we
want to come to office
and work and i think that will remain as
a benefit
and that change has been made possible
so i think
but there is a large section of people
in india for example
the nature of their job is such that
they can never work from home
if they don't have work they will sit
idle
so i feel that when we talk about work
from home
we also have to be sensitive to the
uh as sensitive to the point that this
is not something which will be
beneficial for
or would be actually of use to anyone
and everyone so i think i wanted to set
that
context stewart a little bit before we
move on um now i think
i will come to the point on that the
cross-section
of learning as well as how you can
leverage digital tools for that
right what we have seen is that the what
we expected
uh in the world of learning in 2030
digital tools have
actually uh fast forwarded forward to
2020 2021
so uh the ivy league colleges which at
one point of time were beyond the reach
of many people are now something that
any youngster anywhere in the world in
india can aspire to be part of
that suddenly we have seen digital tools
democratizing the entire process of
learning
now it is not something which is uh
accessible only to those who are
prosperous
who come from rich families or who have
extraordinary level of you know scores
maybe and i think that is something
which we all stand to benefit
and when we are seeing that explosion of
learning that is happening where you are
seeing content
uh very easily consumable made available
to you and you do not take advantage of
it i think it's a i call it professional
suicide
in the current context that when
learning is so easily available
and it is made available to you in a
modular manner um
easily consumable manner it's something
which
there is the shelf life is never ending
of the learning
it is not that uh if you do not attend a
lecture at a particular point
you have lost that opportunity these are
benefits we didn't have
and today that's made available to us
and i feel that uh it's a huge
opportunity for today's youngsters to
maximize on it and
give a different trajectory to their
career which otherwise today
is going to be increasingly dynamic
uh increasingly unpredictable
uh as we move forward so i don't know
whether i answered your question the
second question or an office
no i think you didn't you brought up an
interesting um very interesting point a
couple of them
uh in the preamble to your question when
you talked about
the work from home issue and the fact
that there
are large swathes of the workforce
who do jobs that cannot be done remotely
and these people are sometimes forgotten
in these
these discussions of who is an essential
worker and
and you know what can you do through
digital means but
um on the point of learning
uh you talk about shelf life and one of
the aspects of
the shelf life of the courses is
important because you you can go back to
digital courses at any time
and sequence them the way you want to
but
the flip side of that is the shelf life
of skills is not
as long as it was so could you comment a
little bit on that i think you're uh you
might be on me
i i can you hear me yeah oh yeah i can
hear you yes
yeah the shelf life so could you comment
on the shelf life of skills and why it's
so important to
to keep uh refreshing and replenishing
that
absolutely i think uh um
even today in today's time i mean some
people are aspiring to become an
engineer some people
again i'm all of the aspirations that
i'm talking about are typical
aspirations in india
so people are asked aspiring to be an
engineer aspiring to be a doctor
aspiring to be a lecturer scientist and
so on and so forth
um and we we are we have been
groomed and coached since the very
beginning that
um if you if you get yourself in a good
college good university
a good professional degree that is
enough for you
to have a great life for the rest of
whatever that's true that's absolutely
that's not true that is probably one of
the biggest lies my parents have told me
uh it is not the end of the journey in
terms of learning
because whatever i was taught in school
might have been beneficial to land me my
first
job but will not keep me in that job and
which
will not take me further which means
that and why
because that's not relevant anymore
or it has done its job and the world is
moving on
which means that the skills which were
in demand uh
yesterday could very well become
redundant today
and if i do not want to be at the
receiving end of that
redundancy i need to be able to keep
learn
keep learning the new skills at a very
steady space and my pace of learning the
new skills have to be
much faster than what's happening in our
environment
and hence how about picking up up
and again if i have a choice if i have a
beat if i have a preference or a knack
then why don't i do deep research in
those areas
and keep myself updated across so if i'm
interested in technology
what is that area that probably there
could be a future demand in skills like
for example data security cyber security
are the new things i could be a tech
professionals but for me to have an edge
why don't i invest time in picking up
these
skill sets um i might be a great
programmer once upon a time
but am i keeping myself abreast and it's
not just technology because
that's a common mistake as well most
people do
where we feel that technology is one
area where the demand for skill set is
the most i know i mean i
for example sales the way we used to
sell
10 years back five years back even one
year back is changing today
like now sales people are not able to
step outside their homes
but they're still expected to meet their
targets they're still expected to do
their numbers and meet customers so have
you invested in those digital skills for
you to be able to sit at home
and be able to maximize your leads
i think absolutely important because
what was relevant what made you a star
salesperson yesterday
if you keep doing the same thing it's no
more probably relevant because the world
has moved on
and hence if you're not investing in
adapting and picking up new skill sets
you will be uh
you will miss the bus
and um also to your
point um it's not
just the specialty skills in one area
that you need to have
it's becoming more and more important
for people to be able to
have the complementary skills sometimes
those are
other technical skills sometimes those
are soft skills
we've had some discussions uh with our
audience
um past webinars about
the importance of storytelling skills in
in marketing analytics
you'd think that yes i understand why
you want to tell stories
as a marketer to customers but you need
to be able to take the data
from your analytics and tell a story to
your management
about what is happening and what you do
about it so
um yeah the importance of
learning more about your field but
learning
the complementary fields that build a
career-based very important um
what do you think these changes are
doing to the structure of the workforce
you talked about social capital
talked about how do you manage employees
when they're not in front of you
and whether or not that remains the
situation
what have we learned and how will it
change in terms of
the way we build our teams the way we
manage our teams and
the kinds of jobs that are going to be
available
sure i think employment has morphed from
a
lifetime contract to a taxi cab
relationship that is
short and intimate i think organization
structures now
look more like our glasses or eiffel
towers rather than pyramids
uh i mean that's essentially what's
gonna happen staffing
per se and i'm talking about staffing
from the aspect of how organizations are
going to start their organization
staffing now is viewed as a number of
concentric circles with the shrinking
inner core of permanent employees
organizational life expense expectancy
an average
employee tenure is declining companies
are compelled to think about their cost
structures
uh companies would be inclined towards
variable cost structures which would
directly impact the compensations and
salary bills
moving more towards performance based
and less fixed
employees will surely aim to be more
fluid flexible and agile by rethinking
the effectiveness productivity and
digitalization of their people supply
chain
what is essentially going to happen
stuart is that
uh which i mentioned a little bit is
that there will be this
um as against in the past where
organization used to have this
large base of permanent employees and
then they would have these
outer layers of a lot of outsourced
uh work in different capacities
happening around the permanent employee
base
what's going to happen and the shock
that many organizations have gone
through during the pandemic
organizations would like to actually
shrink that inner layer of permanent
employees and it would be a
small uh you know dot uh and then you
will see that
there would be these bipartite
contractual relationship
there would be these tripartite uh
contractual relationship which are
temporary in nature
uh you will see a lot of apprenticeship
being done by organizations that would
be another layer outside
and then the ultimate and the final
layer
around it all would be those of
freelancers and gig workers
so i think rather than having a
two-layered approach
which most organizations have had in the
past
organization will just become more
resilient
invest in these five six concentric
layers
around the core layer of permanent
employee base
and move ahead with that and why is it i
mean
does that seem unfair actually if you
look at it from
it's important for business to sustain i
mean if
um for wages to be paid we need
employers and for employers to success
to survive and sustain themselves
given the increasing uncertainty around
us
this is essentially a win-win model
which actually
creates opportunities for individuals
but
also ensures that organization remains
resilient so i think
this is how i look uh 2021
and going forward how workplaces work
workforce structures will emerge and
change
that uh it's a good opportunity for us
to ask a question of the audience and
i'd like to
to do this one and
it's basically a simple question and
i'll share the
the slide for the people in our
streaming services
but this is you know are you a good
worker
so the question here is
yes not now but i have been or no
and
so we'll leave this open for just a few
more seconds
it's a simple question but it will give
you a feel for
who in the audience is or has been
a gig worker and
let me share the whole result
that's uh interesting
in our audience today um you know about
one in seven people have been has been a
gig worker and
or or uh what is a gig worker i should
say
one in five have been in the past
but the vast majority two three-fifths
of the people
have are not and have not been gig
workers
and what you're what you've been saying
is
um it's time for those people to start
thinking about changing that in the
future yes
i think that's you should have that
weapon in your arsenal if you're gonna
take on
the future i think you should make
yourself available because
uh while it is fluid a work arrangement
but it also could end up being um
distinctly high paying
if you're able to maximize your time
and your productivity around some of
these assignments and these are
assignment based
you enjoy the flexibility of being able
to do when you choose to do it but it
also
actually uh gives you an opportunity to
maximize your earnings
side by side and in india i don't think
uh there is this mindset that it's only
the uber drivers and the ola drivers and
the swiggy
uh these delivery boys are the ones who
are
only the gig workers yes the the vast
majority
and by numbers they out beat probably
all the other gig workers but we do see
an emerging trend in technology
in media in marketing where there is a
lot of geek work
opportunities and people are making
themselves available
and i think it's it's it's it
it doesn't it it doesn't really you
always have an opportunity
of opting out but then you should make
yourself available if you can question
uh you mentioned the opportunity to
maximize
your earning potential uh would you like
to ask the audience that question about
um
their view of gig worker earnings or
would you like to just go ahead and
discuss that
um i i given that there is still
probably a very few people
who are in the audience who are engaged
in gig work
i mean i don't know it's very simple um
if i have um i have a weekend for
example
which otherwise in a normal work i'm off
work
right i am on i have i have leaves or
these are designated leads but i do have
time available and we are sitting at
home these days we are not doing
anything
so i why can't we just decide that okay
let me use eight
hours or nine hours and pick up a gig
assignment which i will
finish off in probably two days three
days and
maybe why just two three days i can say
that i'll do it every weekend
so i guess um it's about our changing
change in our approach towards work um
i mean if you are somebody who's willing
to invest that kind of time that is it's
not that you have to
um somebody who is uh who is like a
college girl there's a lot of college
kids today who would like to spend time
who and
i know a lot of college kids their
brilliance in some of their
uh media skills and digital skills
um just they'd make that choice that i
am going through along with my studies
pen
give three four hours a day when i will
pick up a gig assignment
and this is essentially learning by
doing also
in some form and it gives you exposure
it gives you experience and it gives you
me helps you make money
so why wouldn't you and there are a lot
of geek platforms now emerging
for different kinds of job roles beyond
the ubers and the holas and hence why
should you not take a look at it
and make your choice you can always opt
out here the best thing about
gig work is that you're not bonded to it
by any means there are no notice
feelings
you can leave when you want to leave
um and your point about college students
is
is well taken because you know
historically
you'd learn by doing by taking an unpaid
internship someplace
and today you have the option of
you know taking on microwork that pays
and progressing through that
that way the other point i think to
build on that what you said is
if you have a weekend free and
why not do something with it that's
productive um if you
if you're not if you don't have your
heart set on taking this weekend off to
do nothing or
to go to somewhere else which we're not
allowed to do a lot of places
but um one of the things that you can do
with that is
is to devote it to the learning that
you've discussed which is
another way to look at
look at that as to do gig work on
yourself you know
you're doing a temporary job to improve
your your future
earning potential yeah
completely i mean you use weekends use
after work
all the time that you're saving not
going out having those dinners
i'm sure can be put two eyes used right
now
i would like to ask um one question of
the audience if i may um
and this is what i'm going to ask
what is your career strategy so let me
open that and i'll display the
choices for the people watching
streaming
um so if you're what's your ambition is
it's for
to progress at your current job
uh is it to look for a new job in the
same field that might
give you more opportunity for growth or
pay
do you want to pivot to a new career do
you want to become a freelancer a gig
worker
um do you want to become an entrepreneur
because these are the kinds of things
that people often tell us
are part of their ambition so
i thought it would be interesting to ask
and see who in the audience feels
um which direction is best for them
and you might be interested to see these
results
what we see is that the most common
answer is to
seek a new job in the same field
and some people want to pivot to a new
career which is also an interesting
thing both of which are
are ambitions that require
looking beyond your current skill set
um being you know a bit more ambitious
about what you can do and
who might be interested in it so um can
you
comment on how that's going to um
play out for people in 2021 and beyond
uh so i'm just i'm just summarizing the
question that you want me to answer is
that
um or other stuart just summarize what
exactly you want me to respond to
because i i can think of
i can think of a lot of responses seeing
the poll
yeah so as we've been discussing
you know the restructuring of the
workforce right permanent employees
becoming um
a smaller proportion of the workforce
and
freelancing gig work becoming a bigger
proportion um
how does that trend
affect um the trajectory that
these uh folks in the audience have said
they'd like to follow with a new job
with
a career how would you advise them
to take action to play off of the
new structure of the workforce and to
prepare themselves for it
so i'm try i'll try and attempt uh a
response or rather i'll try and share
with you all about
how you can make yourself successful uh
in 2020 and beyond in spite of all the
uncertainties
and in spite of um keeping in mind the
aspirations that you might have
i think uh what we thought was uh was
our future is
already at our doorstep so a lot of
trends regarding
work that we have discovered during the
pandemic like
remote work online upskilling
on demand work have been
institutionalized by
the pandemic so i mean aligning skills
to the job requirement
was always the criteria for being job
ready and would always be
however questions regarding which skills
to prepare for
are getting very difficult as a shelf
life a particular
skill which we discussed a while back is
decreasing dramatically
so job seekers need to be prepared for a
combination
of soft skills like the ones shared
earlier um
i mean which even stuart probably uh
mentioned
briefly swaddle towards uh digital
capabilities the debate
these days is increasingly towards the
importance of generous skills as against
specialized skills
and this shall get amplified so there is
this
new book called range written by david
epstein which talks about this trend
and further says in a wicked world
relying upon a single skill
is not only limiting but it is
disastrous as well
so just to conclude this point i like to
draw everyone's attention
to some specific skill sets uh
attributes that you need to invest in
keeping aside your functional competency
so if you
have them uh in your respective
functional
you know specializations it will
definitely help you
remain successful and will also help you
probably aspire a little more than where
you are i mean whether you're looking
for a
better job in the same industry whether
you're looking for
career break whether you're looking to
switch
will help you uh and i must say that
that one particular point that stuart
mentioned about storytelling it is
it is it is if you if you if you all
develop this ability it's life-changing
and there is enough and more content out
there which will help you
sharpen and fine-tune this skill
i i meet a lot of people who are very
high on
iq but because
of their um this inability they sometime
after they grow for four or five years
they reach
a plateau um they are not able to break
through
when into leadership roles because they
have
um run out of their ability uh
to actually be able to narrate
conceptualize
and be a brilliant storytellers because
finally
uh you need to be a leader who's able to
imagine and inspire and hence this is a
skill set which is given
the earlier you start the better it is
but leaving that aside
i think i know it might sound very
repetitive
but digital literacy is going to be very
key i still meet
uh youngsters who uh do not give as much
importance to this skill set as they
should
your ability to navigate through
different kinds of tools
systems can be able to differentiate
between different digital mediums
and be able to structure your thoughts
communications across each one of them
your behaviors across each one of them
is very important
learnability i know it seems like a
cliche but
if you do not come across as a lifelong
learner if you're not somebody who
automatically exhibits that yes you're a
learner profile
then you will get into trouble and i
know it is i mean
it just to share with you my own
personal experience
uh yes um i i used to be
a prolific reader uh and then there was
a time
in my career especially i think when i
third or fourth year of my getting into
my corporate life
uh i always give reasons of my business
to not
being able to read enough and not
getting time and so on and so forth so
there was this dramatic slump and
something that even my friends could not
understand because
i was known to be a prolific reader and
i did notice how that changed and how
that impacted my career
how that actually limited my thoughts
and after that i think i made some
conscious
effort just to share with you uh every
day
i read six business newspapers by
default whether the
paper gets delivered to my doorstep or
not because of the pandemic
i will make sure that i go through all
of them uh
every day there will be one hour that i
keep aside where i will pick up a book
and read
um everybody says there is 24 hours if
everything else has to be done well
these are things please
treat it as oxygen for yourself so you
need it every day for you to be able to
survive and grow
agility ability to handle ambiguity
i think pandemic has shown us
the importance of this skill set that
the people
or the workplace employees who actually
um actually emerge as victors and able
to do in being able to do that will
always have attentions
of their managers of their leaders and
hence
and it's important for you to be in
unpredictable and develop that so you
cannot get psyched you have to develop
that ability of solutioning through such
situations
coding skills i mean coding is not just
anymore for technology guys all of us
need to actually
learn a little bit of coding and coding
has been made very easy
if you just go online there i'm sure
simply learn can also give you some tips
on this but
there are enough and with enough and
more freeware out there through which
you can develop these skills
i mean i know uh chro of one of the
largest
conglomerates in heavy industry
conglomerate in india
uh he actually at that
at this age when time picked up
uh python for and i was
like i was taken aback that but he felt
i mean even a person at that age felt
that he needed to keep up and so that he
can understand
what's going on and i think it's a life
skill now
fungibility many of you in the poll
actually said that you would like to
be able to make progress in the same
company or same industry or the area of
work
um i think you should actually keep
yourself absolutely liberated on that
front you should be developing skills
which should be able to which you should
be able to use anywhere so if
today you're working for a printing
publishing company tomorrow you should
be able to work for e-commerce company
because you never know which one is
going to get affected because of what
so i have had enough employees same time
last year
who completely found themselves jobless
and while i was keen to put them in
different job areas but they were just
not able to
manage or think so in a world where
our job is better than noja fungibility
is a very important skill set
flexibility
like your ours your your um
the kind of job uh roles locations
you need to keep yourself extremely open
about all of that
so if you invest in these areas and this
is becomes your focus
whether there is a pandemic whether
there is no pandemic
i feel you will win and score
yeah richard the one one thing that i
noted as you were
going through those points is that so
many of the things
that will help uh people in the audience
be successful um in the coming year and
beyond
um are not things that are tied to
[Music]
learning a particular skill or
the way we think of a technical skill
it's learning
how to be adaptable
in a general sense
you talked about fungibility being able
to take your skill set
and see how it can be applied in other
industries
um flexibility of being able to
fit into different roles
working hours and that type of thing you
talked about
adaptability you talked about
learning to learn or
flexing the learning muscle and being
seen as a lifelong learner you talked
about
um the the uh
feeding your brain through reading um
all
and all none of these things um are
you know you have to take a course in it
these are all things that are life
skills that
that um you can practice certainly and
you can get advice on
um but they they're um
they're all available to all of us
that's what i'm trying to say about that
um
and then of course there are the you
know particular skill sets and
number of the people in the audience i
think we can um if you have uh
if start with we can move on to the
questions and answers
um uh so
we have a number of people asking you
know specific questions about
you know what jobs are going to be
um popular in 2021 and that type of
thing and
i think it's it's i know a little bit
about
ritu about what you're going to say
about that but um why don't you go ahead
and say it
yeah i think first to comment on what
you mentioned the reason
i uh i cannot and i shouldn't and i
mustn't
talk about specific skill set
which are which somebody can go and take
a course on
simply because today they might seem
relevant tomorrow they may not and i do
not want
to misguide you so i think uh but
these these partic these skill set that
i talked about
while they seem something that you can
do sitting at home
it's like we all know that we need to be
healthy and we should
exercise every day but we still don't do
it
so and if you need inspiration for that
sometimes that's why people get a
trainer or they get somebody along with
them to sit and exercise
do draw your inspiration to get people
to question you
who can hold mirror in front of you in
any of these areas
if you can't do it alone because till it
becomes a habit
if you need hand holding go reach out to
coaches mentors
who can actually be honest and be those
mirrors for you
uh in terms of what are the jobs that
are going to i mean i've been dealing
with that question i mean i've done
sessions exactly similar to this last
year at the same time
right and i actually will give you an
answer i mean again i think it's an
answer which is essentially for me
a guidance if i may say so about how you
should judge where you should go fishing
right uh so i think it's very important
for
all of us to evaluate the financial
prudence of the companies before we jump
to anyone
any job role with any of them as a
pandemic
actually has exposed companies which um
had or managed their cash essentially it
has differentiated organizations which
have managed
manage their cash well uh and they were
able to be more resilient as against the
others
so there are from my perspective you
need to be watching
out for five kinds of organizations and
and if you map those organizations
you'll know where you need to go
cash flows i mean any organization which
is burning cash
at a very steady pace please stay away
from them in the current scenario
net debt companies that have borrowed
money relative to their earning
are the worst affected during the
pandemic and again
you need to stay away cost structures
companies that have more fixed
cost in their cost structures will be
more exposed during the pandemic
and hence please look at
how their costs are aligned like people
who've got a lot of
um fixed costs and assets in their
in their financials are going to run
into rough weathers
extremely people intensive or people
dependent
businesses have been hurt
in many aspects discretionary
items like lifestyle products uh fancy
items that are out there have been
affected so it's important for you to
look for essential services
companies like healthcare banking
telecom power there is a more likelihood
for you to be able to
get some opportunity in these sectors in
today's time as against discretionary
services like lifestyle goods
hospitality tourism
aviations so this is one way you can
construct
how you would uh where you should go uh
fishing but if you want me to tell you
about
industries where there is demand of
course there is healthcare i mean you
all know healthcare now needs doctors
nurses paramedic fibrologists
and the works in pharma they need r d
people
production staff supply chain fmcg
companies
especially the stapled and processed
foods which are
still even even when there is lockdown
they always remain in demand
production sales distribution logistic
professionals
e-grossers delivery agents executives
supply chains logistics professionals
e-commerce
similar delivery apps similar profiles
um fintech companies there is demand for
a lot of technology
uh professionals cyber security
professionals
data security these are india right now
the supply of some of these skill set is
much lower than the demand in spite of
the pandemic
online education uh digital workforce
solution companies
digital marketeers all of them will are
continued to be in demand and hence uh
maybe i mean i'm just giving you a huge
bouquet you can choose what you want to
do
um so
let me see if i can look at a few of
these questions
i'm reading a question do you want me to
pick once uh
yeah go ahead while i go through a few
of the others
so i there is a question i'm an mba
first year student now i'm scared to get
job after the completion of mba because
of this pandemic
so what can i suggest
um i mean look
for me unfortunately this is all better
for the javo because
i have um i've received similar
questions
last year as well and hence for me this
is all our data
but i think my my my suggestion to
you would be that please start
networking with your
alumnus and get yourself into all the
professional networks
which are available
yes should you have started uh two years
back
yes but better now than later
you need to make a target list of
organization target job roles and please
make the target list
not what your preconceived notions about
the past was based on today's reality
which sectors are hiring target the job
roles do deep research
not shallow research and
please have targeted reach out to
stakeholders now most of the decision
makers or hiring managers are available
on linkedin rather than making a generic
reach out to them please have a specific
uh reach out and focus less on your
resume and more
on what value creation you can do for
them
honestly people do not care about your
degree
about what you did people care about the
role they have the opportunity and how
you can create value
also understand that pandemic has also
created a lot of remote working
opportunities
so do not worry about your base location
and the jobs location
if you think you're fit for that job
make a case for yourself so that you can
um so that they can consider you right
and the decision on whether
you should move or not it's something
that you have to make based on how
important your career
job is to you at a later point
so just work on some of these but
meanwhile i don't think you have time
i mean consider it as a sometimes um
a job is better than no job if you're
able to pick up a project a short term
assignment
a gig assignment an apprenticeship
internship whatever be the color of the
job please pick it up
right now right now it's more important
for you to keep yourself
occupied uh and learn through the job i
mean you will not your career will not
transform with just a year of your
working
please use your initial years of working
to create the foundation of learning on
which you build your future career on
that's a great piece of advisory too i
mean the the idea that
um in your first year of work
you're contributing to the company
you're working for but you're also
building um your reputation your
knowledge base your skills base your
habits
and um preparing yourself
for an entire career to follow um
we have a question from a youtube
audience uh
it's kind of a general question or
open-ended question but will automation
impact the world and i think the
real way to look at that is how will
automation
impact the world and and
you know what do people need to know
about that for when they're planning
their careers out
uh automation will impact the world
and it has always impacted the world
since
the time mankind
learned to innovate so
again indian audience may relate to this
uh i'm sure in a lot of um
indian movies which were picturized
which would which were
the which were based on our historical
past you would see that there would be
these specific people fitting in
different households
whose job was to manually operate a fan
this there was this big fan those hand
like a mega version of those hand fans
and that was their job
by the way that was it the whole day
they would do that they even like with i
don't know whether they got to sleep
also at night but that was their job
and then came the fan now from that
perspective
did the fan take away the job of that
person
who was sitting and doing that job of
course it did
but you know i actually i think it's
towards a better
uh better world finally we do
there is a lot of work which is
not dignified in nature which is done
manually today
and gets passed on as work as a job
uh i think human mind is capable
uh anything which can is repetitive
anything which is standardized in nature
if technology tools and automations can
do it better
then why not let them do it while human
minds and intelligence should be
invested in innovation
in creating in building relationship
because that's a skill set that can
never become redundant
and hence but yes is have we reached
that world no
but i can assure you with every
automation
we are creating different kinds of jobs
we do take away some jobs but we create
different kinds of jobs
and which compels all of us as a society
to
grow go up the skill curve because
that's how our aspirations of higher
wages
better life can be met so
we need to create an ecosystem where
automation and constant reskilling and
skilling of
the people coexist and if your question
is if automation is going to lead to
lesser jobs
there is no empirical evidence to
suggest so
at all it is definite but i can give you
empirical evidence it is going to create
better quality jobs
we have a similar kind of um historical
mythology in
the united states of you know the the
vast untamed land that was conquered by
people who went out
cut down trees and made farms and
we still have this kind of
national view of ourselves but in fact
today only about two percent of the
people
in the united states work in agriculture
and if you try to
to convince people of that fact they'll
say no no
we have to have much more farmers than
that to feed ourselves
but the efficiency of farming and
the fact that people don't have to spend
all day in the fields anymore means that
we now have
all the other skills jobs
consumer goods uh healthcare and
everything else that
a modern society has so
automation you know is
not something necessarily to be afraid
of it's what you think you don't have to
adapt to
you said something which actually gave
me an ouch moment
so and i do give this example many times
to work
two percent of your workforce is in
is in agriculture in the united states
62 percent of our workforce is in
agriculture in
india our food grain production
is almost equivalent to yours
so what it means is all those people in
their farms are not productive they're
just merely hanging out there
and that's what we need to change you're
understanding like p
there are a lot of people in the in
agriculture in india but they are not
productive
so they are actually you don't need so
many people in agriculture
but they are in agriculture why because
we've not been able to create
alternate job roles for them outside of
agriculture
and agricultural innovation okay
has not happened and that's not a good
thing i mean these are unproductive
people
and they're they are not earning also
anything to talk about
so that actually is a good point to
raise because i use it very often
two percent and 62 percent in india yeah
it's it and but the trajectory hopefully
will
will follow and and that's
um an astounding prospect of what that
human capital will achieve when it's un
uh unshackled from you know having to
do subsistence um we had a number of
questions about data science and a
number of people are interested
in entering the field and moving into
the field from other
areas one person in the construction
industry
is curious to know about the potential
of data science
jobs within construction
and whether you know in general are is
data science an area that you would
recommend people
go into and and what
skills or prerequisites would they have
to have one one
person is asking because they feel they
aren't good at programming
and yet they're they think data science
is an appealing field so
is that something that they can achieve
or is that an unrealistic dream
you do not have to be a i i might be
overreaching my boundaries but from
whatever little i know you do not have
to be a programmer for you to pick up
uh or get into data science but yes you
need to be in love with numbers
because that's what you will see day in
and day out so i guess
if you're somebody who does not get
overwhelmed with
numbers um and is
and is somebody who intuitively likes
spotting trends and patterns with
numbers you will enjoy this
and i think it's now that there are
different courses and curriculums
in data science which is which which
doesn't take into consideration what
your
what your background is so
please at least give it a shot and try
and pick this up there is not one single
industry by the way
which will not make use of data science
like my industry ours is a people supply
chain
organization i could do wonders if i
make investments in data science
similarly whether it's real estate
construction
fmcg company fmcd company
you name it pharma you can't today data
data science is what it's nothing but
you're basically doing looking at data
and trying to
make intelligent predictions using it
you're trying to understand customer
behavior you're trying to understand
buying patterns you're trying to see
impact of different
correlated or unrelated aspects on your
business
so it is definitely interesting but it
is something which the only prerequisite
in my mind is you should like data you
should love the data and numbers
and and to your point about uh
industries ritu
we've done a couple of recent webinars
with uh
founders of fintech firms and some of
the people in our audience have asked
about fintech and how to get into it
it turns out that the topics of these
webinars was
the importance of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
uh in driving fintech so um
the very nature of that industry
is um data science based
so um we're at ninth
uh we're almost ten o'clock or a little
after ten o'clock so i think we're
past our time um but i did want to thank
you
so much for this um we're going to do
one last question of the audience before
we say um goodbye to you
and this is going to be um
a question regarding learning
specifically what kinds of things
are you interested in the audience in
learning and when do you feel would be
the best time to start
as somebody has said today is all the
best time to start something
um but i'm putting up the poll question
i'll share it with the
folks on the stream
and
should be getting that here we go
there we are
and i'm going to go ahead and close the
poll
and we will see what the results are
data science and machine learning ai are
two of the most popular topics for
people to learn
project management also in cyber
security or all the things that we
mentioned today
um and right away it's by far the
the most popular answer to the question
when you would like to start and i think
that's a good answer
so what i'd like to do now is uh reader
thank you
very much for for uh sharing with us um
your your thoughts and your expertise
today um i'm gonna
um let you say goodbye to the audience
as i share
oops sorry i'm going to share with the
audience the
contact information for you
excuse me
hit the wrong button there
and
so again thank you to ritu
um here's your linkedin
information probably uh just by googling
or each partner
that you will reach the right linkedin
entry
and um again you've been
very generous with your time and your
knowledge today so thank you so much
thank you so much take care everybody
stay safe
thanks thank you steward thank you
bye um bye-bye we're going to
thank our friends at freshers world um
who are some of the people who uh
sponsored this and promoted this webinar
and
it is part of the team lease family of
companies that the duty runs um
number one job portal for freshers in
india and
so if you are a fresher looking for a
job
uh take a look at freshers world if you
are
looking for gig work and other jobs take
a look at the other team lease
companies and i'd also like to mention
and i've dropped this into the chat
once i'll do it again here is
the program that simply learn offers
called skill up it is a free program
it has a lot of our learning content
the self-directed video part which we
offer
access to for free
over a thousand hours of video content
and several hundred skills
including all the ones we talked about
today and many more
and it's a good way to get started
on your learning journey and see if
this is right for you so i've just
added that again to the chat we have the
link to go to that page
um we will be having our next webinar
a little over a week from now thursday
may 13th
it will be an evening webinar in india
and
habits of highly effective engineers
basically a career management master
class with ragavandra gandhari of
tesco and sharing
the
ways in which a person in a technical
job
can be more effective
so we hope you'll join us then we hope
you'll join us on our
social channels facebook twitter
linkedin and
we look forward to staying in touch with
you and
having you at future simply learn
webinars
so thank you very much and
have a great day
you